Scott's in San Francisco hi Scott
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show sure
what's up I got a question for you so my
dad has a started a family so I'm trying
to take over the business and kind of
make things better
he wants to buy trucks and trailers
because he starts panicking because it's
really close to crack season and he
seems to think that's the best wing off
that Vietnam you know for taxes rather
than saving money or we've never been
able to save his home he's under
business over 25 years and he's never
been able to save really mm-hmm well
that's why um you know is because he
keeps spending money on debt to buy
stuff that he didn't even need to say on
taxes all right the the math that he's
doing is unbelievably faulty okay so let
me give you an example what would be a
typical purchase it would be the size of
the equipment $50,000 item 100,000 right
out so if he buys a $50,000 item in
years past he had to he could not write
that all off in one year he had to write
it off over five years so it's a $10,000
a year right off and if he has a $10,000
you're right off you don't get to say it
doesn't save you $10,000 on your tax
bill okay instead what it does is it
would save you about $2,000 on your tax
bill now what we're saying is is that he
borrowed $50,000 to save $2,000 a year
on his tax bill for five years yeah the
math is really really faulty there and
so what happens is entrepreneurs either
don't think this through and or use this
as a rationalization to buy toys inside
their business that they really can't
afford so you guys have to quit buying
equipment until you can pay cash for it
and then and then you're going to buy
older used equipment only equipment you
need to do the job we don't buy anything
here in our office if we don't have to
have it to you
the job done we don't buy anything in
the tax write-off the way he explained
it to me is he has to have because it
has to be moved because it has to be
safe he doesn't want to buy something
that's all of us gonna break down when
it won't be safe into it the first time
and it's out for 10 to 15 days he just
lost a lot of money that's the way he
explains to me and I told him telling
you're telling me all two-year-old and
3-year old tractors aren't safe and
break down all the time
again asinine it's absolutely asinine
that's just ridiculous okay and here's
the other thing it's kind of a dr. Phil
moment he's worked his butt off all
these years he has no money and dr. Phil
would say how's that working for you
it's not you know so how's that theory
of yours working out here it's not
working out and so I don't know how to
tell you to tell your dad what today
he's probably not listening to you and
he's probably not listen to me then if
you're running it then you get to make
the decision and you and I have just
decided you can I don't want anybody to
be unsafe and I don't want to have
equipment I've got probably a million
and a half dollars in equipment sitting
here within 15 feet of me right now
while we're doing this show I can't have
that equipment going down the show would
go down that would cost me a lot of
money just like that but but we also
don't buy equipment we don't need and
then we make a decision whether we're
going to buy new and we certainly pay
cash for it and whether it's cameras or
computer systems and in your case it's
actually heavy equipment we don't own
any heavy equipment a couple pickup
trucks to do delivery and stuff around
here and one bus that keeps running us
between buildings but other than that we
don't have any big stuff like that but
still I can't have that bus breaking
down all the time but I put that bus
used Donald Harris drives our bus every
day runs us back and forth between our
little shuttle between our things and
it's it was a you shuttle and I paid a
tenth for it when a new one cost and
it's run I mean it's broken down a
couple times and we rented a shuttle for
that day when it broke down kept kept
moving I'll put it in the shop and fixed
it but I mean for that little bit of
inconvenience it's safe and it's been
reliable enough to get the job done and
not shut us down and so that's a minor
example but it's filling in the same
metaphor and so yeah you can you can
make this work by use to pay cash for
your equipment otherwise all you do is
work for nothing all you do is end up
with no money for all your work because
and the you know the heavy equipment
dealer gets all your money and that just
doesn't work for me
I don't live that way